Укрпошта відкрила перед замовлення марки
переможного Нового року зі серії що
присвячена віці чи російській агресії
офіційну вартість одного аркуша 88 грн
та чи виросте ціна так само як у випадку
з попередніми воєнними марками крайній
випуск був присвячений звільненню
Херсона і викликав ажіотажний попит
ця марка є особли
Вою коли ми України відразу було
відкрито перед замовлення на купівлю
цієї продукції і місця відсотків тиражу
було продано за перед замовленням тому
цю марку є вже по всій Україні
номінальна вартість однієї марки Херсон
- це Україна становила 12 грн але вже за
кілька днів її продавали значно дорожче
помітили експерти ціна росте буквально
От коли хтось купує марку і виходить вже
за
запоріж Укрпошти щоправда всі опитані
новоспечені власники Херсонської марки
категорично заперечували намір її
перепродати Україна не продають ближнім
родичам подарую
Ну 5 годин в мене онуки є онуком залишу
для себе для пам'яті
потім ще з найпершого тиражу як
поз'їжджаються всі друзі з-за кордонів
після перемоги всім роздам як пам'ятник
сувенір водночас в Укрпошті не
виключаючи частина покупців Такі має
намір заробити на перепродажу марок
завжди поштові марки України це
філаделісти які збирають і люди які
вважають залишити це напам'ять своїм
дітям про те це ну поштова марка
документує історію хроніку події А є ті
хто купують для того щоб потім
перепродати і можливо направити ці кошти
на допомогу збройним силам України
тим часом ажіотаж навколо українських
марок охопив не тільки Україну а й
поширився на міжнародні майданчики
продажів самі перші марки з першим
кораблем які були продані на
інтернет-аукціоні eBay член Київського
товариства філлеталістів продав за ці
два листи на великих за 6 тисяч доларів
хоч наразі в Україні ціни на воєнні
марки значно нижчі філателіст все ж не
радить розглядати їх як інвестицію що
дасть швидкий прибуток пов'язаний
по-перше з війною ажіотаж такий
розпочався дійсно з першого Корабля А
особливо підігріло ажіотаж до філателії
це те що Корабель пішов туди куди його
послали Якщо вам не пощастило купити
марки по номіналу в укр- від Укрпошти то
я би не рекомендував купувати зараз їх з
рук за Шалені ціни для того щоб
сподіватися що найближчому майбутньому
вони будуть там ще більш дорожчі Вони не
будуть дорожчі вони трошки впадуть в
стіні по відношенню до тих цінних є
зараз але там через років
15-20-30 може більше вони дійсно
можуть коштувати набагато дорожче як
інвестиції це можна розглядати в тому
числі як і матеріальні от але не варто
сподіватися що ми там станемо
мільйонерами крім того В погоні за
оригінальною маркою не треба забивати і
про ризик бути ошуканим шахраями спалах
інтересу до України в світі призвів до
того що присвячені Україні і її
протистоянні агресору марки мільйонними
накладами друкують навіть африканські
країни що перебувають в орбіті
російського впливу так вони поповнюють
свої державні бюджети але філателісти
нарікають на велику кількість
фальсифікацій таких марок які друкують
не африканські та азійські поштарі а не
чисті на руку ділки а от українські
марки крім історичної та філатеристи
цінності мають ще й художню яка вже
визнана в цілому світі стверджує
філатерист протягом цих останніх 30
років відколи
Україна стала незалежною Вони завжди
відзначалися високою художньою цінністю
це власне також підтверджується тим що
протягом буквально останніх
трьох-чотирьох років марки Укрпошти вони
регулярно займали якщо не перший то
завжди призові місця на Європейських
світових конкурсах цю думку поділяють не
тільки філателісти а й Прості українці
Мені дуже подобалося марка з мрією вона
насправді настільки Я знаю не таким прям
розійшлася з широким тиражем але мені
дуже сподобалось я за нею голосувала я
за нею Ну я її купував в мене Вона є і
мені вона дуже подобається До речі з
кавуном Мені теж дуже подобається це
мабуть Ну дві